[Music]  tonight at CBS NCIS says goodbye to one  of their original cast members pauley  perrette yeah she actually predates the  show because she was on jag but she's  been on NCIS for 15 years and Polly  stopped by et to tell me about her final  bath  I really put my heart and soul into  shooting the final episode my whole goal  was to give it all for the fans in this  exclusive preview a gunshot wound leaves  Abby fighting for her life will she live  or die will there be a chance ever ever  that Abby could come back I'm not gonna  answer that question mm-hmm no spoilers  here but Paulie did confirm this will  see her character's apartment for the  very first time and it is a goth  Wonderland the fans have been asking and  I've been asking to for 15 years it's  like where does every love it so now we  get to see it and it's fabulous  [Music]